zwei bürger zwei preispunkte
steuerdelikt wir finden heute heraus was
besser ist oder ob sich der vielfache
preis für einen burger lohn einkaufen
erster stopp hofladen premium ketchup
asiatischer supermarkt nur für
fechenheim
rostocker fans jetzt kommen wir zum
wichtigsten part im fleisch und ihr seht
schon besonders jetzt war es okay wenn
man dafür ein bisschen mehr zeit wir
wollten nicht dass gekostet das wird
krank leute ich bin ernst froh dass wir
nur noch den discounter müssen weil mein
portemonnaie tut schon langsam w wir
gehen jetzt aber rein besorgen alles und
dann geht es ans kochen als erstes
bürger brötchen als nächstes hat
flaschen und zu guter letzt chubb und
mario
[Musik]
dagegen auf jeden fall bedeutend
schneller wir haben für den luxus
einkauf drei stunden gebraucht und 4 45
minuten mal schauen ob sich lohnen wird
oh mein gott leute wir stehen hier vor
den zutaten und das hier ist wirklich ja
er werde gleich erfahren wie viel es
gekostet hat zunächst einmal ihr könnt
jetzt ganz kurz pause drücken für euch
überlegen was denkt ihr kosten die
zutaten für den billigen burger ich
zeige es euch jetzt und ich sage so viel
das hat mich überrascht wie wenig es ist
5 euro und 82 cent für vier bürger
anderer seite ist immer noch teurer als
bei merkels und man macht es selbst
trotzdem leute das ist wirklich krank
und jetzt frage ich mich natürlich wie
viel kostet der ganze spaß hier drüben
hat wehgetan es sind 106 euro und 92
cent und ihr fragt euch jetzt woher
kommt dieser gigantische preise
unterschied wir fangen mit dem kleinsten
preisunterschied an ketchup drei euro 79
cent ist schon mal knackig wenn man sich
überlegt dann haben wir die bürger warnt
drei euro 80 versus 79 cent okay hier
haben wir mario 99 cent sieben euro 20
und ihr merkt das große ganze bleibt
noch aus drei euro 29 versus
100 euro also 94 euro aber what the [ __ ]
leute das muss wirklich einen welten
unterschied sein einmal in meinem leben
habe ich war gegessen und ich schwöre
euch ich habe es nie vergessen und ich
glaube diese bürger heute werden einen
neuen standard für mich setzen aber wer
weiß ob das ganze stimmt im endeffekt
kann es natürlich auch sein dass bei der
zubereitungsart nämlich bei smashed
bürgern vielleicht sogar dieses fleisch
die billig variante gar nicht mal so
abschmiert und jetzt habe ich noch eine
beichte zu machen leute wie machen die
bürger nicht als hamburger sondern wir
machen cheeseburger und ich werde bei
beiden bürgern
american jazz verwenden ich weiß viele
leute sagen das ist unmenschlich dass
mit wachs zu kombinieren aber ich glaube
daran dass das der heftigste burger käse
für smash burger ist dem es gibt und wir
brauchen die binde fähigkeit von dem
american schießt um unser gewollt des
vario was nämlich auseinanderfallen wird
überhaupt zusammenzuhalten okay genug
geredet wir fangen an mit der
zubereitung das wasser läuft schon
zusammen freuen sich auf beide für super
lecker jetzt kommen
[Musik]
was wir als erstes machen werden ist das
vakuum wolfen und wieder kühl stellen
weil das ist wirklich so marmoriert und
hat sohn fettanteil das ist schon bei
raumtemperatur zerläuft dementsprechend
müssen wir da wirklich vorsicht walten
lassen gerade weil wir so ein gutes
stück fleisch halt auch nicht verhunzen
wollen und deshalb hab ich mir jetzt mal
meinen fleischwolf und ich sag euch eins
leute mit das komplizierteste an diesem
gesamten video heute waren diese brioche
burger runs wir sind eine stunde herum
gefahren bei drei verschiedenen
bäckereien hainer hatte welche und dann
haben wir in dem delikatessen steak
laden noch welche gefunden immerhin und
ja wir werden das jetzt richtig schön
langsam auf jeden fall laufen lassen
einfach weil möglichst wenig temperatur
möglichst wenig hitze entstehen sollten
wenn wir unser war wolf radio aus der
kühlung raus und leute ich bin wirklich
ein bisschen aufgeregt wenn ich mit
diesem fleisch arbeitet weil ich weiß
wie besonders das ist und wir schneiden
auf und das ganze hier heraus ist zum
glück wirklich durch das kurze
runterkühlen bisschen härter als normal
das heißt aber auch dass wir schnell
arbeiten müssen sie schneiden streifen
oh
mein gott alter
das ist nicht mehr normal alter großes
fühlt sich ganz krank anders schneidet
sich obwohl es runtergekühlt ist und
deshalb ein bisschen härter wie butter
gerade in so einem burger alter ich
glaube es gibt keinen burger place
zumindest in deutschland wo man das
überhaupt bekommen glaube ich für wie
viel würde dann der bürger im angebot
sein also leute unserradio
unfassbar zart marmoriert kommt jetzt in
unseren wolf hinein und da kommt es
funktioniert es funktioniert deutlich
hatte angst dieses fleisch zu leisten
indem es hat eben nicht vernünftig
gehäuft werden kann aber das sieht
wahnsinnig gut aus so richtig schön grob
und daraus fahren wir gleich unsere
kügelchen für die smash burger patches
oh mein gott leute
[Musik]
ganz ganz ganz wichtig so wenig wie es
irgendwie geht verschwenden wir haben
jetzt die unser gewohntes war diese
kleine schale beinhaltet 100 euro bürger
live alles was da drin ist haben wir
schon überlegen müssen wir vielleicht
noch als kleines theater oder so jetzt
kommt erstmal ein wenig salz drängen
damit das ganze auch gleich schön bindet
und dann knete ich das ganz ganz lose
zusammen bevor wir es noch mal in die
kühlung geben aber er merkt leute klebt
gut zusammen das macht was es soll das
wird wirklich eine ganz kranke nummer
schnell die kühlung und wir machen mit
dem günstigen fleischwerk wir
portionieren jetzt das günstigere
fleisch und zwar machen wir daraus 100
gramm welchen
wir machen pro bürger 2 100 gramm bälle
über ein bisschen salz und pfeffer dran
und das konnte dann einfach klose
zusammendrücken wir wollen gar nicht
dass das so gut durchgeknetet masse wird
sondern es soll wirklich einfach
bisschen zusammenhalt bieten also durch
jetzt nicht nur von außen wenn es so ist
kriegen wir diese schöne kruste dann
auch endlich auf den grill special so
war ihr war wieder ein kühlschrank
wirklich so kurz draußen wie es nur geht
ihr werdet spätestens wenn es auf dem
grill liegt verstehen warum einmal
drüber verfangen und gleiche geschichte
100 gramm pro kugel wobei wir hier ein
bisschen mehr druck drauf gehen müssen
weil das war einfach sonst verfällt aber
in berlin ließen beide so locker so
aufgeregt so weil das zu krank hier sind
unsere beiden burger band und ich sage
es so viel ich habe das nur gekauft weil
es zu teuer ist ein bisschen bescheuert
aber das ja der sinn des videos an sich
schwöre ich ja auf die brave bürger man
sich zum beispiel bei rewe oder aldi
auch gibt aber die war ein bisschen
teurer sehen auch relativ lasch ausfällt
ist interessant und leicht gelbliche
farbe und hier drüben haben wir die
billigsten bürger bands von aldi sind
standard aus wie man die beispielsweise
von eben bistum kennt oder so zwei
stiche butter damit tust mir das ganze
jetzt eben draußen an und lässt das kann
man ruhig auch ein bisschen vorher
machen weil das braucht nicht super
lange und vor allem halten gut an
gekostete bürger waren es auch ihre
kruste ihren kranj ein bisschen
verteilen ordentlich auflagefläche und
dann bleiben sie ruhig außer das fleisch
an zu branchen
[Musik]
neid hatte zunächst der etwas billigeres
mesh bürger gerade auf fleisch drauf und
session für bright runter session sagt
so viele leute auch wenn er billig ist
der wird krank und ganz wichtig er
braucht einfach nicht lange in dieser
methode verlassen dass kur zu liegen
damit sich eine schöne kruste aufbau
klippen schöne kruste schießt doch da
mir noch mal kurz erhitzen wir legen das
zweite partie obendrauf damit haben wir
eine schöne topfit aus dem käse und dann
war's das auch schon eine seite kommt
freundlich meyer und auf eine seite
kommt catcher leute streiten sich gerne
über zur geschichten die bürger rezepte
aber das ist so puristisch und so simpel
das ist eigentlich nur gut sein kann
guckt euch das an unser geheizt weiter
und wir testen sofort so ich habe
natürlich auch wieder tester anstalt und
zwar meine geliebten geschwister
sebastian tabea kommt rein ich werde
jetzt unseren bürger einmal vierter zack
zack und ihr lasst einfach nur den
geschmack würfen und entscheidet ob das
euch taugt oder nicht und behaltet den
geschmack vor allem ganz wichtig im
hinterkopf während leichtes anderen test
habe der weihnacht sebastians erst
saftigkeit ist da sagt trotzdem leicht
medium sogar das ganze
was so ein guter leichter kranz auf dem
brötchen drauf meine these lecker es hat
vielleicht nicht besonders bridge sa
gemeinsamen klasse
man kann dieses fleisch die ist günstige
vielleicht noch keine andere art und
weise so saftig zubereiten geschmeckt
schon sehr gut aber ich will schon sagen
was luft ist also für ein smash burger
da geht schon mehr
leute weil ich bin ganz aufgeregt ich
bin ernst ernst aufgeregt der grill ist
wieder auf temperatur der gleichen spaß
beginnt von vorn und jetzt bitte passt
auf was jetzt abgeht ich werde
vielleicht stimmt dieser ganze laden
zwischen der geruch märkte das alles ist
hier am sprudeln und wirklich leute
jetzt gleich werden wir erst sehen ob
das überhaupt funktioniert
das war besser das ist normal dass man
für diese kunden als er privatleute das
es erlaubt tarifvertrag und rüber
schnell das ist nicht mehr normal oh
mein gott du kimaiyo 7 eur 20 mio ihr
seht diese gelbe farbe charakteristisch
regionale ketchup ist ein stück ich
einfach ein bisschen weniger industriell
vom look bevor uns das da drüben würde
ich jetzt auseinanderfällt achtung mini
misst tropf und wir geben es jetzt ich
kann es fast an
gott und drauf da wo mein gott ich hab's
geschafft unser 50 euro war wie bürger
der mittelschicht
profitiert ist sagt drauf es kommt erst
das so bitte nehmt euch was wichtig im
kopf zu behalten ist das den 40 fachen
preis nicht
das ist die große frage für sich zu
greifen und habe der 1 83 und wer ist
das nächste bastian ich fand das fleisch
es habe beim anderen fasst also dass die
unscheinbare ausweis das bisschen wenn
man müssten jahren küste nicht was einen
erwartet wir müssen nicht was was das
aber wieder alles internet verläuft
premio de bühne
ich bin sehr gespannt eltern habe ich
dann aber das fleisch dabei du spürst
dass du vielleicht pause reise ja da
30 widerstand dass hier geht einfach
gegangen aber jetzt einmal nur den rand
manche ohne soße
hammer ganz ehrlich ich muss sagen es
ist fast sünde das mit soße zu essen
dafür wenn ich also diesen rat gefasst
und das war so stufenleiter das ist
wirkt war ketsch abschreibt und das ist
für mich grund dass wir wieder zu machen
bei chips ab weil nicht das fleisch
fisch probieren das schmeckt unendlich
gut
besser
aber er bekommt deine meinung noch ist
es keinesfalls 40 mal so viel wert 40
mal so viel der gang dieser kombi besser
man wolf selbst nimmt irgendwas was fünf
mal so viel kostet wie das billigfleisch
dann läuft der hase oder also es ist
unnormal aber es ist die sache nicht
wert können wir glaube ich alle
einstimmig sagen oder fühlt sich
schuldig dabei und man fühlt sich
schuldig weil man dieses stück fleisch
so verwertet hat leute ich hab es für
euch getan ich hätte das ganze wirklich
gerne lieber als steak angebraten aber
nichtsdestotrotz wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder bestimmt machen
auch nochmal test teuer das ist billig
und mir ist übertrieben heißt ich
geradezu gegessen haben wir sind diesmal
macht gut